[Music]
hi everyone
welcome back to our Channel
today we have a unique figma tutorial
ready for you
we're going to create a circular slider
for a website's hero section so get your
figma file ready and let's dive in here
we have our basic layout for the hero
section already set up just beneath that
you'll see we have a few images of
smoothie bowls and fruits ready to go
the first step is to create a circle
that is going to serve as the base for
our rotating Carousel of smoothie bowls
now let's go ahead and copy all the
Smoothie Bowl images into our circle
make sure to distribute them evenly
around the circle so we can create a
good flow for our slider
all right
once we have all our bowls nicely placed
around the circle we're going to select
all these images along with the circle
itself and create a group now move this
group into the hero section frame
carefully position it so that we're only
able to see the pink bowl at the
Forefront
next we're going to give our Circle a
bit of color let's go with a vibrant
pink now let's go back to our collection
of smoothie Bowl images
copy all of them and scale them down a
bit
once that's done we'll place these
images right below the paragraph
these will serve as our handy selectors
to switch between the bowls
to help our viewers know which smoothie
bowl is currently in the spotlight We'll
add a white rectangle just below the
pink Bowl
finally We'll add some drop Shadows to
all the bowl images this will give our
design a more 3D and interactive feel
[Music]
now we're going to duplicate the frame
select the circle with all the bowls and
rotate it just enough so that you can
see the next bulb that's to the right of
the currently displayed Bowl you might
need to play around with the positioning
a bit to get it just right and here's a
little trick let's also rotate the
individual Bowl
this will give the effect of the bowl
also turning as it moves into view
now we're going to tweak the colors and
visuals a bit to bring everything
together
first let's adjust the colors of our
page to match the new smoothie Bowl
this can really tie the design together
and create a cohesive look and feel
next we'll play around with the Shadows
a bit
we're also going to change the color of
the paragraph
with our light background we want to
make sure the text has enough contrast
to be easily readable
for the Final Touch let's switch out the
fruit in the background
we'll replace it with these mango pieces
to match our smoothie
change the pass-through property to 20
so that the fruit doesn't overshadow the
text
foreign
moving forward
duplicate the frame we've just created
select the circle that includes all the
bowls and once again rotate it just
enough to bring the next bowl from the
right into view
let's match the page colors to this new
bowl and move the rectangle indicating
the selected Bowl under the next Bowl
[Music]
tweak the Shadows a bit to ensure they
match with the new color changes
foreign
ly replace the background fruit to match
the Smoothie Bowl currently displayed
now repeat the entire process for the
last frame with a blue smoothie Bowl
foreign
don't forget to adjust the color shadows
and background fruit accordingly
[Music]
fantastic
to make our design even more vibrant
let's apply a drop shadow to all the
bowls currently in view
this will give us a nice 3d effect
[Music]
and now on to our final and most
exciting part where we'll be creating
interactions between frames
this is where we truly bring our design
to life switch over to the Prototype tab
in the first frame select the second
bowl click on the plus sign and drag it
to connect it with the second frame
choose on click as the trigger smart
animate for the animation ease out for
the easing and set the duration to 600
milliseconds let's ensure that our users
can also go back to the previous Bowl
not just forward use the same details as
before enabling our design to move both
ways
let's continue by creating an
interaction between the second and third
frames
keep the interaction details consistent
with what we used before
and for our final interaction let's
connect the third and the last frames in
the same way
now let's preview our prototype and see
how it performs
the Smoothie bowls are rotating
beautifully when we're moving forward
but not when we're going back
but we can fix this easily
the trick here is to adjust the
positions of bowls in subsequent frames
for instance
if we want the pink Bowl to rotate when
going back we need to rotate it slightly
in this Frame
now when we preview the Prototype again
it works as expected
repeat this process for all the bowls to
ensure a smooth rotation in both
directions with that final tweak we've
created a beautiful engaging animation
that will truly bring your designs to
life don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more creative content and
inspiring design ideas